I've been lucky enough
not to lose anyone
I love except my grandfather
to actual mortality.
But that doesn't mean
that I haven't experienced
symbolic death, symbolic death
in the form of love lost.
There's a reason that
melancholic movies get
under my skin and why I can't
look at most Instagram photos
for more than a few
minutes at a time.
Because I get sad over something
I haven't necessarily lost yet.
Falling in love is like
staring into the sun
and finding that
instead of blinding you,
it illuminates you.
And all of a sudden, you
went from being blind
and then you can see.
It's the moment of
feeling like you
are complete for the first time.
Roland Barthes says, all
of my desires, abolished
by the plentitude of
their satisfaction.
Love is fulfillment.
Love is to overflow.
Love is spill over.
Love is aesthetic arrest.
Love is the italization
of experience.
Love is getting caught up in
something larger than yourself.
Love is radiance beyond
all previous limits.
It's consummation,
it's consecration.
It's a dance with the divine.
It's, I went to God just to
see, and I was looking at her,
reflected right there
in front of my eyes.
That's love.
And so when you lose
love, when you break up
with somebody you cared
about, somebody in whose arms
you felt the promise
of forever, and you
felt the promise
of eternity, you
of souls merging.
And then to contemplate
the idea that there
was a time when we were
together, and now we are not,
how could it be so?
How could it exist, that once
we were us and now we are not?
And then you look at old
videos and old photographs,
and you can't
believe that there is
a reality playing
back there for you.
You are seeing a
replay of something
that was real and
tangible and solid.
And where'd it go?